hello welcome back to new rockstars
we're gonna do something a bit different
today so you know we here in new rock
stars we make a lot of predictions about
TV and movies and a surprise surprise
they're not always right and now the
time has come for our annual
self-flagellation a discussion of what
we got wrong in 2018 and if you think so
we got right cuz it's been a bit of a
mixed bag America showed me today is
Philip Molina we're drinking we're
drinking we're kicking back we're
thinking about the past and it's it's
fine it's fine so uh take a look let's
get started and let's start off with
HBO's West world so in West world the
past year I theorized that we could see
a host version of Anthony Hopkins
character Ford and that this is who the
man in black was talking to in the
trailer so you can if you go watch our
trailer breakdown you can see where that
happens so what actually happened is I
believe he was talking to the character
Lawrence and that Ford was like uploaded
to West world's version of the cloud but
in the trailer there's like a part where
you kind of see someone who's wearing
like a black vest a white shirt it seems
that you only see him from behind and
I'm like oh what if Ford comes back in
the park as a younger version of himself
and that's how I'll get reboot as a host
yes I'm like they've improved the
technology to th people they can show it
for several minutes at a time they have
HBO's budget on things I was way wrong I
was furious with in the moment this is
probably the worst mistake that you've
ever made
it keeps me about and I bet a lot of
people watching or like I'm so glad they
brought this one up I know they probably
had forgot for a while and you forgot
Westworld was last year yeah those of
you lone shooters out there can just
cross this one off yeah fine fine they
repented yeah no come on like this is
the kind of thing you've made some like
doozy mistakes oh yeah by the way swing
I don't feel bad calling them out cuz
I've signed off I'm pretty much
everything yeah your prediction anybody
like we we have a conversation about
most of these before you put your face
and you're the one that says it and then
I get to stay in the background and
succeed when you get it right and
scurry away when you don't it's an
imperfect science that you have to throw
so much against the wall and some of it
will stick and then you can just claim
success on the things that do stick but
a lot of this stuff just you forget you
ever said but I think we have a pretty
good track record yes you know the ones
that we get wrong are hilariously wrong
now fun to look back at them because if
you want to knock out a park you got to
swing hard you guys swing away at the
fast balls like some of them are gonna
whiz by the bat oliver landed that
metaphor I slid into a touchdown okay
this is a good example though also of
like it's you know like work we have to
search for the thing to get wrong you
know you don't you don't do so bad we do
do a lot of research and and try really
hard to take some really solid guesses
so I think there's some pride here even
though we have shame and you know about
these moments especially in that text
message thread where we just go off on
each other constantly
you got your heads on that yeah speaking
of our next most rage-inducing mistake
man but this almost like a bummer though
that we don't get this one right we made
an entire freakin video about why Logan
would win the Best Screenplay Oscar
mmm-hmm yeah I didn't really it's like
the Academy didn't even watch the video
yeah why aren't they I thought all of
our subscribers were Academy voters the
yeah it was it was nominated it turns
out what actually one was the adaptation
of called me by your name which which is
barely featuring superheroes right
anyway I mean there might have been some
background story I'm sure we could do a
theory video and retcons a superhero in
this memoir of a some kind of power but
that way no normal peach the it's a
fantastic script and I think even though
it didn't win its it's worth reading I
think you know we were just so happy and
excited to see a superhero adaptation
that actually has like an artful
approach I mean we compared it to the
script and the movie Unforgiven the
Clint Eastwood West Western which swept
the Oscars you know people love I kind
of me voters love westerns well and I
think that we were going out on a limb
and it's it was a little less about like
is this script good enough to win we
thought it was it was
enough to win we were kind of going out
on the limb of is the Academy ready to
go okay some of these movies are
freaking good yeah it seems like they're
getting closer to it especially with
into the spider-verse this year is
getting a lot of attention and looks
like it could at least win the animated
category but hopefully we'll score a
nomination for Best Picture will it win
probably not because once you get to
that point once they've crossed that
threshold you really just talked about
like politics and numbers and it really
weirdly is a numbers game you start
looking at like what is the political
message of the movie what kind of year
is it right now is that they you know is
it the year of women or is it the Erb
representation is a year where like
journalism wants to be celebrated so a
lot of these like the your spotlight one
was here we wanted to like her
journalism so it's it's a weirdly like
political question to ask which movie
will win Best Picture
well which was why they were trying to
satisfy that with that popcorn
Oscar basically which movie right that's
tasting popcorn and Logan like I
remember that was an example of movie I
was like I don't want it to win a stupid
popcorn one like yeah so much better
than that yeah and they that's why they
dialed back that pop quits going back
and saying maybe we will do the popcorn
thing I think they're just trying to
tease us into watching yeah that's
honestly what is another weird political
numbers game at that bright where
they're trying to get more superhero
movies so that people watch it yeah what
else we get wrong okay well in the venom
trailer breakdown I speculated that we
would see all five of the Life
Foundation symbiotes what was they
figured we saw one of them we saw a riot
those rizzo meds one but there's also
like scream agony Lasher and phage and I
just thought because they were adapting
the Life Foundation storyline from the
the venom lethal protector storyline
that we would see all five we I even
looked into like color it's it's I think
color lighting and trailers is the thing
that trips me up the most because I'm
like oh it's a slightly yellow light
that means it got a real bad one coming
down later oh yeah just based on colors
certain color just completely threw me
off but we saw right I think that's
probably for the best right that I was
wrong on that yeah well I mean I think
to me that it was kind of you know no
offense because I knew this the whole
time that you were wrong on that but I
was like they're gonna that's what they
want for a sequel that's how they keep
designing these things right is like
let's introduce them to one weird thing
and then for the sequel let's give them
way too many of the same thing right in
the comics they can get away with this
because that's comics are all about like
just throwing so many different colors
at the people as possible so like if
your kid opening up this comic book it's
awesome to see different like venom
spin-offs that each is a different color
you can identify they don't really have
clearly fleshed out personalities in
fact as they move on from the liter
protector storyline they only follow a
couple of them they follow riot a little
bit they follow scream scream comes back
but the wrists are kind of like oh yeah
they're still part of the world they
come back for another storyline yeah but
they aren't this is example of creatives
trying to throw as much against the wall
see what sticks and hopefully just run
with the stuff and claim success on
those you know what's interesting is I
think that you know we we I think we're
kind of in the middle on how much we
like the venom I think there were things
we liked things we didn't like I would
say that even though I kind of a second
ago jokingly said like this would be way
too many there is a different entirely
different structure of a movie that does
have you know a lot of these symbiotes
out there and it's more a little bit
more like invasion of the Body Snatchers
or something where it's like you you
know like think Eddie Brock is like
riding a train and it's that kind of
paranoia of like how many people on this
train might actually be a symbiote and
like just say that distrust of the world
around him also reminds me a little
especially cuz they can move from each
other they a little bit of that other
movie we record sometimes with the
whistling it gives away who like who has
currently the Denzel movie kind of a lot
it's like a murderer keeps like shifting
bodies whistling you guys correct us in
next year's I mean you do see that in
like the thing and the faculty and so
these two especially because it's in
that contained location you guys got to
watch the thing is basically trying it's
like a better version of yeah the thing
was definitely a reference point for
venom not just in the whole idea of like
oh this shape-shifting thing but like
the the visuals they try to reference I
mean they did use a lot of CGI whereas
Carpenter famously used practice yeah so
we'll see cuz actually like once I hear
that he
amazing pitch whoever just came up with
that I think that that's a sequel
actually would be excited for so now we
have to see whether or not the Sony
venom universe is going to survive the
movie did well overseas and right now
they're doing this huge push on the home
homeless mhm the blu-ray in the digital
that like it could make enough money
where we might actually get to see some
that that which could be cool
Sony seems to be getting back on the
right track I think with her I mean into
the spider-verse is one of the best
adaptations I've seen and that's
actually a good example of how you can
bring in a lot of different colorful
characters you just have to be careful
about how you structure it and those
other three spider-man spin-offs that we
had didn't come into like the second
half of the movie and in a despite over
so like they were able to like keep our
focus from getting diluted yeah but
let's move on to another one there let's
talk about the Avengers movies because
that's probably been a lot of what we've
been talking about this year is all the
different directions infinity war and
avengers endgame can go and then once
Avengers they need to work him out yeah
we didn't really nail it a hundred
percent there were the old infinity war
trailer breakdowns and one of them
I thought vision would lose a mine stone
but that he would be fine like would you
say exactly he'd be a little rattled
this mine stone his brain he's bring
rift out of his head and he'd be a
little rattled have it like a like a
hangover just be like oh I didn't I
didn't need that it's just an appendix
just sit out and be like it's like a
tattoo
well this is certainly what the Avengers
were hoping for right they were trying
to find a way to bypass it so I was just
like siding with the glass-half-full
mindset that cap had and in the middle
of the movie like there's a way we can
bypass it sure he can just reconnect the
neurons and you know what I'm not the
book is enclosed on this we have another
video coming out where I think there is
a way that vision could still be alive
maybe a little worse than a little
rattled but I don't know I think if
you're if your theory is right that they
can bring him back then I'm gonna say
you're probably right that he would just
be like ouch I gotta sit down the
question though is like where is his
consciousness right you can't you can't
just take away the mine stone and
say like Oh reload Jarvis into this you
know human vibranium infused body this
Android and it'll be the same his vision
the mine stone is a key component but is
it its entire soul isn't it and if so
the mine stone isn't destroyed it's his
soul inside the mine stone now and then
they can just put that real that's when
they were making vision also there was
that idea that they could make
essentially an Android and it would be
fine but it was it did take the mine
stone in order for Humanity and be what
we've come to know and as Paul Bettany
remains but but so I just think that
there's their kind they almost made that
point that like we can't replicate a
real person the closest we can't get
obviously is like Jarvis but Jarvis says
you know kind of Siri
yeah comparison division yeah he's like
Tony Stark sense of humor Siri yeah but
we talked a lot us about a lot of
different theories another one that I
brought up is that they were going to
use Tony Stark's barf technology to go
inside Hulk's memories was something
that I brought up I don't know I don't I
don't really have a good explanation I
actually don't know that I think that
it's not gonna get used before like in
Avengers 4 it might show up I still
think it's way funny to say they're
gonna use Tony Stark's barf here's what
I'll say about it what I specifically
theorized is this something that where
there was like a color basically and one
of the Infinity Ward trailers you see
that shot of strange Tony Stark and
spider-man on epidemis cue ship and then
there's just like a blue color tone to
it so I said oh this kind of looks like
the blue color and that was unlucky
space when he's holding up the tesseract
maybe there are nanos to ship in that
moment and they're rewatching it kind of
like home video footage and they're
using this this bio retro augmented
Framing thing whatever barf is to read
into Bruce banners memories from the
Hulk and and see exactly what happened
because I assumed that Bruce Banner
wouldn't be able to recollect everything
that the Hulk saw which is normally the
rule like Hulk Bruce Banner can't
remember what the Hulk sees the
we just went beyond that and it caused a
bunch of confusions and we made a lot of
videos about this discussing this
question of how can Bruce Banner
remember what Hulk saw their split
identities Bruce Wayne are supposed to
have amnesia from every time the Hulk
takes over so that didn't bring up a lot
of other theories so in a way that like
us thinking about that did lead us to
asking the right kind of questions
it's just our conclusions but we're
depending to where came out we're pretty
wrong yeah and I again I also stand by
like you know there's still a second
half of this movie that it could totally
exactly I use it also even though I'm
busting your balls I think that doing
stuff off of color is I mean like I use
that move to a lot it's because we we
understand enough that like it's not
easy to make you like to have such
consistency between two shots if they're
not shot in the same moment right like a
lot of effort has to would have to go
into like let's make sure it's the exact
same hue so sometimes I mean this little
tip for those of you trying to knock us
off our tower here and you make your own
trailer breakdowns but a lot of times
that is a giveaway is like you see two
moments and there's the almost identical
coloring that probably is within seconds
of each other even if it's you know
split apart in the trail and that kind
of scrutiny has led us to the right
place before like when we I did a
trailer breakdown of the last Jedi and
there was that moment of the last Jedi
trailer breakdown where where kylo Ren
says let the past die and he reaches his
hand out and they edit it to make it
look like him and Ray are together in
that moment and all it was was it was a
different scene where Ray was at a
campfire and so but and whereas kylo Ren
was in the supremacy oh yeah it was it
was on fire after like all the fighting
that they had done so they made it seem
like that they were the same scene but
just because I was like staring at the
sword I'm like oh they're not in the
same scene so I was able to figure that
out
little did I know that the movie would
bypass that by having these forced time
chats anyway so they didn't need to be
in the same location when they talked to
it and I like that you also explained
why your eyes get really red sometimes
yeah but now they don't yeah you know
speaking of staying on like the infinity
war stop for a second there was one
where I was just like that's a huge
swing in one of the trailers I
you remember you were like I feel like
you called me and you were like I've got
it see this lady on the right here boom
captain marvel reveal they're gonna just
like she's just gonna be this gonna be
her big entrance in the MCU she's gonna
hey I was in that room copier you
thought this was her behind cap that is
actually Scarlet Witch Scarlet Witch
it's mom but I you know I I appreciate
the effort thank you that you that went
into this prediction I feel like you
actually had a theory based on like you
were like it's an alternate take on the
costume yes right yeah I this is another
thing why I think colored might have
tripped me up because and I I got into a
Twitter argument with with someone on
this I win it shut up I swear my life on
this green caps things and I and I
tweeted it back at this person I got my
even showed I went into Photoshop and
said this is not the same color as this
and I was dead wrong and they later
stopped responding you were completely
right this is yeah this is see where
they're walking into Avengers HQ vision
and still little rattled from his run-in
with ebony ma or not have any want with
Corvus glaive earlier and then Scarlet
Witch his girlfriend is walking in with
him makes sense that it's his romantic
partners the one with him but for some
reason I thought that Scarlet Witch was
not wearing blue jeans I thought she was
wearing dark clothes so when I saw pants
that were blue I said oh Captain Marvel
wears a blue blue pants gotta be super
like one of the the most powerful member
to ever join the Avengers but they're
like but you're the newbie you get and
you go in the back yeah like she doesn't
get to lead the team at all she just
kind of has to keep like you know what
it was a part of it was conspiracy type
thinking because the frame is a
conspiracy type think that's yeah it's a
pretty dangerous game we've to be
careful going too far because this type
of thinking applied to other things in
life is not healthy but the the way this
shot this is a Super Bowl trailer if I
remember correctly the framing was so
good the editing was so fast and you
didn't see who was walking behind cap it
made me feel like they're hiding
something from us and when you start to
feel like some authority is hiding
something from you that's when he
started to go crazy most of the time
they're not hiding things from you it's
just don't what do we say here we don't
care not Heidi Nancy Oh competence with
conspiracy most of the time people
aren't thinking about as hard as you
probably are ignore it
all right but there's another thing that
we should point about the infinity war
trailer that we were really wrong about
it wasn't just us a lot of people
thought that Thanos is natural facial
scars the three that are natural but
always have them or this this deviant
gene of eternals they all have the same
shirt scarring and they are not given to
him by Wolverines claws so don't rush
past that right yeah well I think a lot
of people thought this was one of our
first shots of Thanos in 2017 Avengers
infinity war trailer and so people were
like looking at and everyone's like
marveling at how well the rendered
everything was looks like actual skin
that you could touch some people want to
touch their nose a bit too much and some
weird corners there but those three
lines I think people who were less
familiar with it I mean it goes down his
chin that's just very close together
slightly delicate Erik I want you to
show what it would have taken what
position Wolverines hands would have
been if I'm Thanos in order to leave
those marks
that's weirdly like into me I didn't
feel that I'm just saying like if I were
Wolverine with anise in that moment it'd
be hard it wasn't like some epic fight
it'd be like don't go really call me by
your name like Wonder Santi other peach
the yeah that's just how they always
look and I think really this was
probably a product of us one team that
the x-men to cross over this right
around we started here the news at the
parks Disney merger was happening
everything oh of course they would have
assumed what this huge merger needs to
be approved by Congress has already
happiness let's go ahead and shoot a
movie it has the number one most famous
to have the other one yeah attacking our
new villain and must have been like a
really shrunken version because there's
a Demeter separation between no scar
that's a remember part of the
negotiation they're like you can have
little x-men it's gotta be an action
figure come to life do you know Toy
Story Wolverine small soldiers so let's
move on to something else no no it's
probably not gonna happen till face for
it okay here's probably one of the
craziest ones that we got wrong my
favorite and it's wrong on so I thought
cap ate the soul stuff okay to be
specific I did said it might have been
inside of him in some way maybe he is
not the word you used I remember was
consumed gobbled yum yum or just laugh
too big okay I thought that maybe he had
eaten the heart-shaped herb of Wakanda
and that that could be the sole stone
because one of our theories was that the
meteorite the vibranium meteorite that
crashed into Wakanda created Mount Bosch
anga that enriched the soil of Wakanda
to create their strong vibranium armor
and everything they use for their
technology and the heart-shaped herb
right you thought it was I thought that
meteorite was the sole stone now the
Russo brothers said no it's it's or I
think what it was as rank Kugler said
that this whole sons not going to be in
black but we're kind of reading between
the lines and the semantics of like oh
maybe the soul stone in its form maybe
either he doesn't
or maybe saying like no it's not the
sole stone in the story of black panther
it's just a vibranium media I love that
the director the movie came out I said
no this whole stone is not in this movie
and we're like we had to read between
the lines here it's what five words you
know like I kind of blame the Russos for
that because they did tells that endgame
was not the title the fourth movie and
then it did end up becoming the title
for the movie so it's it's on them but
one of the clues we looked at was the
color of his eyes right so I've noticed
this thing about about Chris Evans's
eyes is that weirdly when you up the
saturation on this guy's eyes some of
you have noticed this before cause I've
seen comments like does he have two
different color eyes I don't know if
it's something about the actor or
whatnot but one of his eyes like hues
toward orange we just hit the right
light on it if the right Venom symbiote
stands next to him flecks an orange
color yeah he just has like blue eyes
which isn't if you have blue eyes I
don't know enough about the biology
doesn't mean you have less pigment you
mean yeah that you're seeing past the
front layer yeah so maybe if you shine
certain lights on people with blue eyes
specifically it starts to look different
colors maybe I'll say that in this
moment looking at the picture now it's
like you know the berenstain bears
Mandela effect I don't see it at all
orange slices no I mean yeah I think
also it's like how is cap strong enough
to resist usually resists the Infinity
Gauntlet famous isn't using the stones
right now right and that was an
important distinction that infinity war
introduces only when the stones are
naive when he was using them right so we
were just thinking like he should have
been able like smoosh yeah and tie a
nice yeah but yeah so so I want to
clarify there cuz that's actually like I
think there was like three things he got
wrong Oh lots of the soul stone is not
the wakandan root yes I cap doesn't find
a way to use the soul stone and also
there's a you had a in that video if I
remember correctly you actually in order
to connect those you had a theory that
cap would get injured and need to go eat
that root in order to come back that I
also at one point brought up the fact
that the Super Soldier Serum might have
been derived from the heart shaper
because they got the vibrate and that
still might be the case we don't know
the entire can
formula of our skeins Super Soldier
Serum doll he does he's dead he's gone
but it's he said it was like some kind
of mix of steroids and like a little
secret ingredient that he put in there
this probably marijuana yes the but we
don't know exactly what it was and I you
know just assuming that they got the
vibranium for a shield they stole it
from Wakanda what else did they steal
from Wakanda could it have been could
there have been at some point some
scientific exploration was like we can
use this and use this to make our own
black panther in America that's all I'm
Captain America or you know white guy
yeah very very but yeah I'm glad that we
figured out where we're wrong there and
we had a lot of fun talking about that
right yeah the truth is somebody else
pointed this out to us off screen dad
they're like no you guys it's the
captain not eat the soul stone the soul
stone ate all of them
yeah it's very very prophetic for where
we think we're going in the next movie
yeah yeah eight Gomorrah for sure at
least but then also maybe even maybe
every single person that got dusted
deposited now to be fair to Eric though
by the by I we like in like I'm gonna
give you a lot of the the credit run on
this stuff got a lot of things right
like a lot of lot lot of things like to
the point where like sometimes it's hard
to be right I remembered that sort of
get a little uncomfortable for me with
Game of Thrones where I was kind of like
damn like I kind of see I can see I can
see it all right yeah so beautiful but
like for example the end of venom I know
something that you totally guessed it
yeah I think this is something that over
scrutinize a ssin of frames that you
guys give me crap for sometimes but yeah
there's there's a Space Shuttle behind
venom and this is it's not so much that
people didn't see that this shot maybe
last like half a second in the trailer
and so this is really just a result of
me going frame by frame through the tree
which we really do for these trailers
and I'm like that looks like a freaking
space shuttle and I was just kind of
doing some other research I didn't see
anyone else by the time we had shot it
who had talked about it I'm like they're
gonna go into space or like space
exploration is gonna be part of it so I
just went into what are the different
theories for how the light foundation
be exploring space because in another
shot you see something that looks like a
space shuttle with Life Foundation
written on it so I knew um part of
rosamma its characters goal Carleton
Drake well it's going to be space
exploration either harvesting more alien
symbiotes exploring their home world and
some version of that ended up being
actually okay so yeah we can say yeah
check got it yeah access I like that
that entire theory is the things that
sometimes we're trying to communicate
when we have a word on the thumbnail
that says space it's about all of what
you just said is what we were trying to
say with great if you just hit the
spacebar you go to a secret Easter Egg
video don't know that's not a word
that's weird
but yeah I just think it's so funny
sometimes and we're trying to
communicate something as complex as what
you just said of it just like the word
like yeah space yeah okay I another one
that I think we got right was the crimes
of Grindelwald I you know we did make a
couple trailer breakdown since movie
kind of I feel like it kind of came and
went you know a lot of you guys are into
Harry Potter I love Harry Potter but
this movie didn't really make a big
splash but watching it I was kind of
like huh I I feel like I've kind of like
predicted some of this specifically the
the way Grindelwald escaped in the
opening sequence when he escapes from
the the thestrals prisoner transport
from the makita headquarters I looked at
that scene over and over again I'm like
are there two Grindelwald in the scene
is there someone on the inside who has
his wand from like evidence custody who
may be used Polyjuice potion and I just
started throwing out these ideas and I
feel like a lot of you guys gave me some
guff for that they're like no they're
not easy probably that's crazy aim it's
exactly what happened there was an McKee
so or on the inside who used Polyjuice
potion swapped places with Grindelwald
and he was the one who is inside and the
real grand Walt was able to get out get
him to escape and disappear and it's it
happened almost exactly as I predicted I
don't real I missed a lot of other stuff
in there how do you feel about I getting
that prediction right while you're
watching the movie a bit mixed because I
don't want to necessarily get everything
right I only like talking about like
things where there's like an interesting
twist you know I don't want to predict
the entire movie scene for scene for you
it's just if there's like some kind of
like interesting concept or something
that's like fun to theorize about
because I know a lot of the times we're
not going to be right but it's fun to
expect
on the idea of is someone masquerading
is someone not who they say they are is
somebody using people but what's I think
ironic about in this instance where
you're watching it and you're like you
sounds like you lost a little interest
by being right I think that's what this
movie suffered from and why it came and
went is that your average person well it
wouldn't despite the events of what
happened in the movie and the marketing
campaign trying to chuck this everyone
watching this every Harry Potter fan is
kind of like yeah but the good guys win
right like we kind of know what's gonna
we know what characters are gonna
survive to at least if not survive today
survive to be relevant in the Harry
Potter franchise so it kind of took out
that that dramatic conflict or the the
stakes of it even though I may not
remember all of the ads for were like
who who will change the future right
like really trying to push like no it's
not totally set yet but I just think
ironically the same feeling you had is
something that people actually might be
able to relate to of like why maybe they
never felt that excited for this movie
yeah and it felt like you know seeing
the third act to this movie it got
really really complicated with like
familial relationships and who's related
to who and for hardcore like Potterheads
it felt like there was some errors in
the in the timeline right the characters
agency impossibly there were characters
who were supposed to be someone's
brother where actually their parents had
died 15 years before this character
could have been born and I think that
was part of the disappointment too
rather than like a kind of movie that
really rewards fans who were paying
attention the way infinity war ended it
kind of left those fans behind I felt
like crimes of grunwald did to try to
appease an audience who's not really
paying attention and we'll see how this
franchise goes I'm not really looking
forward to but a franchise that we are
looking forward to I think we should we
should maybe wrap up on these things at
least on on I think it's a prediction
that like we might get right yeah but
we're right in the middle of one right
now yeah the the whole idea of Scott
Lang traveling into the quantum realm
and using time travel down in the
quantum realm through these time
vortexes playing a role in avengers
endgame so we've broken down
this post credit scene for a man in the
wasp we've broken down the Avengers
endgame trailer we have a lot more
videos coming out about how this could
be possible I put together my theory for
how the timeline could work in a
ventures in game that seems pretty
bulletproof but there's a couple things
- next year the but we'll see what
happens if you look at the Avengers
in-game trailer the final shot of it
it's it's Scott laying at the front door
of Avengers HQ Captain America says is
this now is this old footage and then
Black Widow says oh no that's the front
door but her answer doesn't answer his
question and I was like why is he asking
that or is he just like saying oh
because maybe he's confused cuz I'm
Scott Lang's supposed to be missing but
in the corner it says archive now a lot
of you are saying maybe the Russos just
put that in there just to screw with us
the word or maybe it's archived but
still not through time travel it's just
like yesterday they missed him by one
day yeah but if you're gonna do that why
would like why not show it sooner like
the narrative possibilities are far more
interesting yeah that's what and to be
clear dude these are were referencing
the fact that this is a prediction that
it was made before the endgame trailer
came out this was specifically just
after the post-credits scene and we're
really harnessing with Janet's lines
about don't get caught in a time vortex
yeah we can't save you yeah exactly I
kind of just felt like well that some it
felt like the biggest eastery coming out
of ant-man the wasp it's setting up for
Avengers endgame and even before that
post-credits scene came out there was
talk about just little clues coming from
the cast and from Kevin Feige the whole
crew about like what kind of vibe
avengers endgame which at that point was
called a ventures for would have psyche
was comparing it to the finale of Star
Trek The Next Generation the finale
episode which is an amazing episode
three visit yeah Captain Picard goes
through several different like
iterations and there's three different
timeline versions of himself just trying
to link to Evangeline Lilly compared it
to her experience shooting on later
seasons of lost which of course delved
into time travel travel and again I got
simultaneous experiencing yeah you see
Kate in the future and
present day on the island which expanded
the whole flashback conceit of the show
from the earlier series and then Tom
Holland said time travel time travel and
he just handed us all the script so I
think we're onto something when it comes
to time trouble if not time travel Rick
and Morty style multiverse parallel
timelines you know yeah some version of
what is it like a shared experience
across time which is a very interstellar
yes
so we'll see exactly how right and wrong
we were with some of these theories as
we go forward we still Captain Marvel
coming out which may answer some more
questions about some of the theories
that are still up in the air we're gonna
move on she wear blue jeans as will it
be blue or well I can figure that again
for lightning around today
our producer put together a series of
smaller mistakes that we're just gonna
but you know these are the ones that we
probably got the most grief about from
you guys it's just me saying a
character's name wrong or me just the
real dumbest things you've ever done in
your life
yeah these keep me up at night so here
we go the first one in Deadpool 2 in my
breakdown I thought that his belt was a
mutant dampening collar collar so in the
opening frames of Deadpool 2ec like it
explodes when he tries to kill himself
and like different his head flies at you
and he talks like how did I get here and
you see like this thing flying and I'm
like oh it's an it's a mutant dampening
collar that hold later used to actually
take the bullet nuts just a belt yeah
that said totally a thing that shows up
in that movie it does I just I'm a dumb
dumb and misread yeah thing your parents
don't even like you I know this one oh
man how god I cut too deep for you in
the was it a drastic world sequel the
dress for fallen kingdom trailer you
said a bunch of times that it was the
indominus rex but one time you said it
was a indus horas and that's exactly how
i the tone with which i read the
comments who say this so yeah it was in
the our movie breakdown of Jurassic
world falling Kingdom which like you
know it's
these things that we isn't part of our
big things that we talk about but it's
like Oh some people are really excited
about this drastic world franchise yeah
let's do a video about it and yeah they
weren't that grateful I would say some
of you were but some of you are real
particular about like the exact
syllables I used to describe dinosaur
names which you probably didn't know
until this movie came out and I didn't I
didn't say write several times into
source Rex and it is a made-up dinosaur
name it's not even in any kind of
whatever I don't care
that's how much I don't care about it
now yeah it's the movie wasn't that good
and oh it wasn't that good so we
shouldn't care about it that much it's a
it's and a source and forget you guys
who this is going to cut to an apology
video all right
speaking of like made-up monster names
so we did it break down the detective
Pikachu trailer and there's a bunch of
Pokemon sightings in that some of them
are just like on posters or
advertisements in the background and in
the kids bedroom there's a poster that
shows like championship league Pokemon
and past like boxing matches and one
there's very clearly a picture of
Blastoise and when I was trying to
figure out who all the more I'm like oh
that kind of looks like the Pokemon
Loudred now I grew up playing Pokemon I
know
Blastoise so much better than Loudred
because I kind of stopped playing the
games around the time Loudred got
introduced but man it is you know
watching again it's very clearly
Blastoise and it's so much that I had to
put the terms
Loudred and Blastoise on my twitter
muted words list because constantly
getting tweeted about how i was wrong
and how could you be so stupid and call
that louder it's clearly Blastoise what
a well you're right I am
that was stupid but it's not okay I want
to be right about this I don't want to
let you guys know I really did and I
didn't want Pokemon to be the thing I
screwed up
tell me more about what happened in the
gymnasium Brock touch me no not fun
stuff
next up uh walkie dead the actor the kid
actor coral coral oh right
yeah he gets a bit he's immune you
thought he was immune you thought they
were did not think he was immune I want
to entertain the question so right like
we thought that Carl might survive at
the midseason finale last year Carlos
bit and then he died at the midseason
premiere is when he finally passed away
and I thought you know Rick and Carl
have been in a lot of close calls over
Carlos over the year over the years Lars
and and I thought there's there's a
theory that Rick might be immune even
now like with Rick being brought to
whatever this new community is people
are like maybe there's something about
his blood that is special and that maybe
they'll be able to derive a Cure from it
so that there is a possibility that Karl
could be immune and I entertained the
question and what like impasse zombie
films what does immunity look like is
walking it different in that way and
Walking Dead has set the rules of its
world to be different that and everyone
has the disease yeah and that's what
well at least the Walking Dead show the
I don't know if the comic books have
been that decisive about how the disease
infects but that was a big moment a show
and Rick said that's what the scientists
told me is that we all have it yeah you
were wrong you should feel bad yeah okay
and this is a big probably the most
recent screw-up in the Avengers endgame
trailer I said Natasha Romanov name was
Natalie I said it's wrong a couple times
and some of you guys been really good
about calling me out on that real good
about it but yes too much and fairness
is something I'm trying to get this
trailer breakdown out to you guys as
quickly as possible so what I've started
doing is right in net an eighty which is
how people that saw her nickname and on
the formatting of the document that I
use it auto corrects to Natalie every
time I wrote NAT so some of the times I
caught it some of the times I did it and
I'm like Ron Burgundy when I'm reading
the prompter my own script I just read
what's there because I just tried to get
through so our editors can start working
on it as quickly as possible so that's
that's what I know her name's Natasha
and I'll say last year I'd yeah with two
even harder and I called her Wanda
because you shouldn't have to Russian
female character names in the Avengers
light up there's plenty of other female
Avengers they brought in why do you have
to bring in Wanda and Natasha why not
just call the
by their superior names called him Black
Widow and Scarlet Witch so you blame me
not a correct on on now I'm blaming
everyone but myself yeah that's what I
was feelin great and finally another
walking dead one I think this one's fun
because of what what it made you do it's
pretty small it seems ma you just
mistakenly thought that Rick had killed
someone in her was actually Daryl yes
but it wasn't like kind of like a casual
like oh and you know that someone that
Rick had killed what did you do instead
I went off on Rick because this is
something where they were in their wars
with the Savior's and and you know there
was a surrendering saviors like that
moment in Saving Private Ryan where it's
like look my washer separ in the G I
shot him and it was supposed to be a
prisoner of war so as a savior was
surrendering and and like Rick had this
whole negotiation with them he's like
just come out surrender we won't kill
you and in the episode Daryl shoots them
and it's his home own or Rick's like
whoa dude guys kind of moment it's real
deep show there but the but Rick and
when I was doing my breakdown of it just
somehow I got confused and I thought
Rick was the one who shot him like what
a moment of a loss of innocence for Rick
where he murdered someone who wasn't
even like posing a threat to him he
murdered a young man who was
surrendering what has happened to her
rig what a monster Rick is how dare he
we must string up Rick and he must pay
for his crimes and we were like Rick
didn't shoot him Daryl did yeah there
all the time
Rick was the one that was trying to say
it was the person who was most of his
negotiating you know things wrong
sometimes but but just the passion with
what you do is what you tune in for
right now we've had a lot of fun times
on camera and a lot of things that you
missed happened behind the scenes and
we've been keeping track of some of the
more fun moments so actually our
wonderful editor Devon it's kindly put
together a nice little blooper reel for
us from the past year let's roll it look
like you're going through this trailer
dozens of times I'm gonna reassemble
what I believe to be the timeline and
chronology of Daryl Daryl canvers Daryl
canvers
Darrell converse sounds like a brand
that you'd see an REI of like like
hiking gear oh you got a Darryl canvers
nice Clinton is taking up this mantle
clomp clomp I think it's only fair
Episode nine includes a mace windu force
ghost yes papa Xena
yes Palpatine desert died I hope it
burns in hell no that's terrible
let's see if we can do a better version
of it Aldi bloopers I'm probably not I'm
I'm the only one that's up and then show
the part where he goes would you like to
know what do you really have this war is
just beginning saying you can take these
vision Mike but we also got up choked on
something in there
gold and silver it's like there's
different variants of berries and like
if you collect the right ones like they
boost your pokemons level they do
something for your fantasy there's like
oh yeah a silver berry yes like oh jeez
the time I spent doing that I think it
was in high school in that first like my
freshman year I think games so far too
much
oh boy yeah those happened no Sam can't
say anything right in real life and
people don't realize how edited it
here's we string together every every
single word it's kind of like it's a
verbal version of the serial killer
letters that they send on ransom notes
just stringing together letters from
different words and yeah yeah well it's
just as charming too it's been a very uh
what a year fun year I would say more
hits and misses mrs. and the Misses are
so much fun to see because you get to
think about and then you watch the movie
and it's just like oh we were so wrong
and the movie was different than we
thought and you want to be surprised
when he gets a movie I'll say that we
like we've had very very mild likes tiny
conversations with people involved in
making these movies I like the Marvel
movies and whatnot and there
is this thing that they kind of address
with like you guys and and people like
you or what's wrong with the world
they're like you guys have made us have
to surprise ourselves you know I mean
like if it's easy you guys are gonna
come up with it too which is insulting
my head but I think that it's kind of
like the Coen brothers saying we're the
Coen brothers at least in the early work
famously we're like if we can solve our
problem in under a week if we can figure
our way out of a problem with our
characters then we can't use that
because it's right to easy if it's
something that we can figure out from
trailers you know and just end up
putting our heads together in you know a
few hours I think that these movies now
have pushed themselves to be out of that
reach and I think we're ending up with
way more interesting stuff because of it
yeah I think it's fun to just like have
these kind of nerd speculative
conversations that we have with our
friends and unlike reddit some
subreddits and bring them into a place
where we're all like talking about
together because it's fun to be a nerd
and to dive too deep into stuff and to
surprise yourself with the types of
wrong theories that you could have
because I you know otherwise it's just
gonna be some like dumb entertainment
critic who you know just talks about
something that you missed and they're
way off about these these things and
they honestly don't want to read their
reviews because they're like 50 and
they've never read a comic book in their
life and have no idea what the
characters names alright they'll call
them Wanda sometimes when their name is
Natasha or Natalie yeah who cares what
they have to say well thank you for
watching guys and keep tuning in let us
know what we got wrong you know we're
not too proud that I'll just mute you
after a while if you keep yelling louder
than Blastoise am yeah we should have a
hashtag chat or something so that you
can mute it over the year but then we
can use it for videos like this at the
end of the year movie hashtag what you
got wrong so main new rock stars newpsie
but comment down below tweet us at new
rock stars and like this video share it
around subscribing to rock stars for you
know all the deep dives into stuff you
love and we'll see you next week and
next year we'll be doing this bye guys
thank you bye